more Pro Hamas Insanity erupting in
Liberal cities and on leftwing campuses
anti-israel agitators out in full force
in New York pelting cops with eggs
bottles and even fireworks 19 were
arrested in the chaos college campuses
also continue to be a hot bed of
anti-Semitism Pro Palestinian professors
and students taking over the library at
NYU while demanding a ceasefire kids at
Columbia University are handing out
Palestinian head wraps and planning a
walk out this week and Harvard's bracing
for more protests after students held a
die in protest Jesus liberal comedian
Bill Maher blasting the snot noos Bratz
for siding with the terrorists don't go
to an elite College because as recent
events have shown it just makes you
stupid there are few if any positives to
come out of what happened in Israel but
one of them is opening America's eyes to
how higher education has become
indoctrination into a stew of bad ideas
among them the simplistic notion that
the world is a binary place where
everyone is either an oppressor or
oppressed the same students who will
tell you that words are violence and
silence is violence were very supportive
when Hamas terrorists went on a rape and
murder Rampage worthy of the Vikings
they knew where to point the fingers at
the murdered and then it was off to
ethics
class Greg Bill M sounds familiar that
is like everything we've said for the
past 10 years I welcome him to this
table I mean you know what it's it's
about time I mean imagine being a Jewish
kid on these campuses right now I mean
you can't go there I mean you get you
have to like basically keep your mouth
shut staging a D in after one of the
most gruesome massacres in history they
deserve to get their asses kicked but
they won't I think what we're seeing is
the death of what I I coined ocean
privilege the we used to have these
moates around us you know they were a
buffer zone and they were only pierced a
couple of times 911 in Pearl Harbor and
some aort Ed homegrown Islamic Terror
like at the Pulse Nightclub but we had
this ocean privilege we never really had
to worry we got complacent in fact we
allowed our our ocean privilege to get
chipped away and it got chipped away in
three ways one our border collaps now
you can get in if you really try and we
might even help you so instead of adding
to Ocean privilege we poked a big giant
hole in it second you got homegrown
radicalism which we seeing now in the
demonstrations and colleges we are
whether we knew it or not we were funed
an ideology on campuses that were
promoting our demise probably for the
last 30 40 years and the process is
ongoing it's a war against the west but
it's from within then you add to it the
contagious brainwash that comes from the
social media we've collaps the barrier
between ideal logs and this country so
now you can get that stuff right in your
your own room and it can spread and and
and and basically the the oppressor
versus the oppressed virus is now on
every campus you have kids who know
nothing about that why do you think so
many people are obsessed with the Roman
Empire right it's because something once
Mighty got complacent assume you know
assumed that bread in circuses would
keep people happy that's now carbs in
Tick Tock and what we're seeing now is
that it doesn't and who knew that if you
got rid of patriotism and religion and
exceptionalism and the value of the
Melting Pot would lead to this well it
has what would you rather have White
Privilege or ocean privilege oh boy
that's a tough one white ocean privilege
I'll answer it for you Dana Pino well I
think what's important here is the
transparency and that is is key and for
as hard as it is to watch these videos
and to know exactly what happened or to
listen to the stories that would happen
it is so important Barry Weiss at uh the
Free Press is doing a great job of sort
of oral testimony to make sure that it
is out there and I would make every one
of these kids listen to it I'd love to
give these kids a map that had no names
on it yet and see if they could tell me
where is Israel oh that'd be fun right
you you know exactly how that would go
the other thing this weekend in ital in
India there was a protest of college
kids and they're out there protesting
they're carrying the Italian flag which
is also red white and green hello like
they didn't even know what they were
doing um but other point I would like to
make is that there was a journalist from
the I think it was new it was one of the
New York New York or New York Magazine
and they tweeted that there had been
evid that hamasa decapitated a child
they got a ton of social media push back
so they did a second tweet and said well
I'm actually not sure if the baby was
beheaded or if the baby's head fell off
after the trauma imagine thinking that
you actually have to say that so that
the online mob won't come after you the
fact is the baby was killed and it was
beheaded that is that is the evidence
that has come out as hard as it is to
hear and I would make sure all these
kids had to hear it judge Janine you
know I wonder if they are evil so evil
that they think that the Jews deserve it
or maybe they're not seeing what we're
seeing maybe they just want to deny that
it's existing and that's why Israel
released the unedited video that Trey
Yang's talked about that apparently none
of the major networks are reporting on
they don't want to talk about how
horrific it is to have these babies be
beheaded or have eyes gouged out or
women burned alive um and and so all
they talk about are the Palestinians the
poor Palestinians there's no mention of
any of the Jews and if they're are they
deserve to die and so you say to
yourself you know they went from cancel
culture you know because they didn't
like what you said or they didn't like
the way you were conducting yourself to
now literally denying the Holocaust re
you know erasing history and now you
know they deny your existence and they
want to deny your right to exist and
that's why they're tearing down these
posters of people and kids who are
missing who are either missing or or or
you know are hostages how can you deny
that Humanity they're evil because if
they're college students they've got to
know how to access this information and
it almost makes you believe that they
are in support of destroying the Jews
and then you have to go back and say
well what have the Jews done to you did
the Jews get up on October 7th and say
let's destroy Hamas no they got up to
try to survive in this tough
neighborhood as it's called Uh of Israel
it's horrific so is this evil seems
pretty evil to me uh I would like to
believe that they don't understand
actually the history of this and what
happened and that their social media
feeds and that was a huge theme of the
bah discussion on Friday that they are
being fed a complete counter narrative
to the ones that we are fed on ours and
the information that we seek out and
they don't have access to good
information about this and we have to do
our best to keep bombarding them with
that kind of uh with that kind of good
information but you know I saw AOC was
interviewed by medy Hassan over the
weekend and she's calling for a
ceasefire and he kept pushing her what
does that mean does that mean Hamas is
in charge said well for a ended up with
yeah for a while that's how it's got to
be and that is not a viable solution the
Israelis won't settle for that and they
shouldn't and the US won't settle for
that and they shouldn't I would
encourage everyone to watch it's a
10-minute video so it's a bit long but
even just a few minutes of it there's a
a business professor at Colombia Israeli
who was speaking out the other night
talking about how now the university
can't protect Jewish students and that
parents need to be aware of this that
this has become a completely unsafe
environment to be in and you see that
this could have a real ripple effect on
people that when you think about where
you're going to send your kids are you
going to be looking at one of these
universities that has a Dean that can't
find the guts or even talk to the
fundraising director look at all of the
donations that are being pulled from
these universities that said if you
can't find it within yourself to say
that my people have a right to exist you
don't get a new library and I'm ashamed
to have gone there and that is not going
to stop anytime soon it's almost as
dangerous as being a conservative on
college campus it's tough up next bomic
is destroying the American dream hey
Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere
else